tom moore is now sir tom the 100 year
old world war ii veteran
was knighted by queen elizabeth for an
extraordinary job well done
mts tayab reports from outside windsor
castle
there was pomp circumstance
and social distancing as queen elizabeth
knighted captain tom moore
in a special ceremony to give you an
idea of just how important this was to
the queen
she briefly left her own granddaughter's
wedding princess beatrice in order to
bestow this honor on to sir captain tom
right here at windsor castle to meet the
queen
was more than anyone could expect
captain
sir tom is credited with boosting
britain's morale during the coronavirus
lockdown
raising spirits and nearly 40 million
dollars for the country's public health
system
by walking a hundred lengths of his
backyard one for every year
of his long life it was amazing for the
kids to see that
you know anyone can do anything it's
been quite the year for captain sir tom
on his 100th birthday in april he was
promoted to colonel
and received a military fly past
what was it like to wake up this morning
being sir tom
a night of the realm arise sir tom
it was a little bit early but i had
certainly
some special feeling i'm delighted that
i'm
i've got this honour from the queen
captain sir thomas moore the ultimate
antidote
in these still trying times for cbs this
morning saturday
in the assayab windsor